so here's a common question can you cry
in space on my second space shuttle
flight I my main role was to be the lead
spacewalker the purpose was to go
outside and build the huge robot arm
that would then build the space station
gigantic multi-jointed very complex very
capable arm
I was outside working I'd been outside
for several hours my very first space
walk and I was lead spacewalker and my
drink bag which just has water in it has
a little Camelback sort of bite valve
started leaking water and I saw some
little drops of water floating loose
like like little ladybugs around the
inside of my my helmet one of them I
don't know what happened but all of a
sudden my left eye snap shut wait in
pain yeah kind of blinded and it felt
like a bug had just got in your eye or
you just put some real nasty liquid
little hot sauce in your eye or
something sir you're my I just stung
like crazy and you can't rub your eye or
it's inside a fishbowl of a helmet you
can't even reach anything with your
eyeball so I just had to kind of take it
and and it tears up of course but
without gravity that tear supply just
builds and builds and you end up with a
bigger and bigger ball of tear on your
eye which in this case was contaminated
real question was what do you do I'm out
on a spacewalk I'm working and I figured
well I got one I work and maybe that's
why we have two eyes I'll keep on
working you know and I won't tell
anybody maybe it'll clear itself but
unfortunately the tear just got so big
eventually that across the bridge of my
nose and went into my other eye and now
suddenly both eyes were contaminated
while I was outside of my first
spacewalk I was blind which wasn't what
I expected to happen
so then I kind of had to fess up call
down to Houston you know I know if I
said houston i have a problem or not but
something like that and and they thought
maybe it was the lithium hydroxide in my
backpack that removes the carbon dioxide
from our exhaled air and lithium
hydroxide is nasty stuff if you start
breathing it so they wanted me to
immediately open the purge valve on the
side of my helmet and let the let the
contaminated air start to flush outside
so it's weird to be holding onto a
spaceship blind and what Houston tells
you to do is now start leaking oxygen to
the universe but that's what I did open
my valve listen to says my oxygen is
hissing away and you'd think it might be
terrifying
really or at least fear inducing but it
was actually kind of peaceful I was I
was just comfortable I was a nice
temperature I wasn't going anywhere I
was holding on to something I could
still talk I could still hear and all I
couldn't do was see
and after we got back in it was like an
eight-hour spacewalk which is a long
time for a spacewalk you're so tired but
after we got back in and looked at it
the thought was probably that it was
just the anti-fog on the visor had
picked up one of these floated or had
been picked up by one of the floating
drops of water and so it was really just
in effect squirting dish soap straight
into your eye this is what it felt like
which I really wouldn't recommend
especially if you can't rub your eye or
cry and so we changed the after that I
think we use Johnson no more tears now
for our for our anti-fog but it was it
was an interesting day in that we had an
important task to do something that
would normally terrify you or me
happened but because of all the training
and preparation and visualization and
thought and teamwork and everything in
advance all it did was slow us down for
a little while
and we completed everything on the
spacewalk and it turned out to be a
successful day